[Musique]
Maurice le chat fabuleux
découvrez l'histoire de Maurice et sa
bande de raccompli
[Musique]
il pensait ronronner sur un tas de
pièces d'or je sens que cette ville est
pleine d'opportunité
allez on y va
mais c'était sans compter un étrange
coup du sort
ok j'ai compris je sais maintenant ce
qu'on va faire résoudre le mystère qui
frappe la vie je n'ai pas vu la queue de
rat dans le coin
il y a une odeur vous ne trouvez pas
c'est comme une odeur de une odeur de
mystère allez chercher l'entrée du
passage secret mais à quoi ça ressemble
un passage secret il y a pas de passage
secret
vous n'allez pas croire ce qu'on a
trouvé
c'est un démon terrifiant
effrayant
un chat retombe toujours sur ses pattes
Maurice
vous devez le combattre
vous allez avoir
[Musique]
je n'allais pas vous raconter la fin de
l'histoire
Maurice le chat fabuleux
ça va miauler au cinéma cet hiver
[Musique]